5 56 into monday morning hey this is a
real tell all your friends alert for
southbound
i-15 drivers heading to california check
this out this afternoon the nevada
department of transportation starts a
repaving project on the freeway between
jean and prim you're going to be down to
two lanes between 2 p.m and 6 p.m
then at 6 00 p.m you get down to one
lane at each direction until six the
following morning now
it might not be as bad as it maybe
sounds for a couple of reasons first
there's going to be no work on weekends
and that includes the upcoming memorial
day holiday
work will be suspended until wednesday
june the 2nd
and the project is planned as a
so-called moving operation
with only two miles at a time being
worked in different stretches the nearly
11 million dollar
16 mile project supposed to take a
hundred work days
at the same time they're saying they
hope it's all done before the end of the
year you are advised to plan on
10-minute delays through work zones but
if you've got the option completely
avoiding those weekday work hours of 2
p.m
to 6 00 am might not be a bad idea you
can go over the closures in the online
version of this story on our website
8newsnow.com when you click traffic then
driving you crazy buckle up drive
carefully please put on that phone
if there's something driving you crazy
email me traffic 8 8newsnow.com